[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome everyone to this exclusive look
at the older scrolls online high isle
we've been working on elder scrolls
online for 14 years and we're still
breaking new ground telling new stories
and continuing to explore this
incredibly deep world we are constantly
growing and expanding along with you our
community and this year highlights that
growth we have a new area to explore a
new game system the launch of spanish
text translation and we'll bring all of
this to you while continuing to make eso
the best virtual world fantasy game
last year we made eso truly next gen
with the addition of native xbox series
sx and playstation 5 clients showing our
commitment to keeping eso up to date and
relevant on just about any device you
want to play it on
there's so much to explore and do in eso
it's almost impossible to describe in
just a few sentences but we truly
believe in our play the way you want
philosophy
eso is so big it's essentially many
different games and experiences in one
which makes it a living breathing
virtual world
just like the eso community zenomax
online has also been growing and
thriving we've learned new ways to work
together while remaining apart and we're
poised to do great things in the future
by being an amazing collaborative
welcoming group
i couldn't be prouder of the studio
and now it's time for the show we have
so much to share with you about high
isle new areas to explore new friends to
meet new enemies to confront a new
trailer we'll be debuting at the end of
the show and of course our new in-game
card game tales of tribute
it's all here so let's get started
cj
when we finally decided to
go off and explore something brand new
after i emailed you for two years
straight asking you please
don't send me somewhere dark again a
little bit be someplace pretty what were
your thoughts my thoughts were i was
very happy that that we it was kind of a
collective agreement like we were all
really excited that we spent two years
kind of you know taking a trip down
nostalgia lane right we had gone to
skyrim with graymore we went to oblivion
with with blackwood and then we were all
kind of ready to like oh god let's do
something pretty again right like not
only someplace pretty but
all new in terms of nobody who's played
an elder scrolls game has ever gone here
before right and so it was all new lands
we're gonna do go someplace that's
gorgeous and we're gonna get to explore
the bretons which is really cool lore so
yeah we were totally excited to sink our
teeth in it was great
so when we get ready to start an
entirely new zone every team has to kind
of do some initial steps right what's
what's the art team's tips
we had in front of us already from the
writers like an idea they were like
we're thinking something kind of
mediterranean paradise island vacation
resort this is where the really well-off
bretons
go this is the resort in their house
right like and immediately concept
artists are you know looking up images
of mediterranean islands
and then the rest of it was these sort
of alabaster cliff faces sort of white
cliffs of dover but we knew we were
close to somerset so we wanted to sort
of play off the rock forms that we had
done in summerset we wanted it to be
clear there's going to be some geography
there that's shared
but it has to look new because we we
make an effort for every zone to look a
little bit different and and have its
own unique you know kind of space and
the art
and we started immediately looking at
sunflowers and sunflower fields and
doing something we've done a lot of like
overhanging dark places you know cool
locations but we were very excited to go
okay can we do open fields like
let's give the players a place where
they can stand and see for you know a
good couple of miles and then have
something kind of really lovely and
listful you know
going on in there
and it's comparable to you know the last
two years size-wise so you know it's
it's big
one of the things i love the most about
high isle
is how grounded in reality it is what
was what was that like like it was it
was an interesting challenge because
we've done bretton's already they're in
high rock they have an architecture set
they have a look and
and we wanted to honor that obviously it
needed to feel like these were more
britain's not different bretons
and so we got to take some of those
original
certainly in the architecture we got to
take those original breton ideas and the
architecture we got to update it and you
know we wanted to do something kind of
new so we we took that medieval that
classic medieval
almost post dark ages kind of look that
the breton stuff in high rock has and we
folded in a little germanic medieval
into that and it was really fun to sort
of
do a whole new set
in that in that paradigm that bretton
paradigm update it make it fancier
you know and and remember that the lore
of the britons is really interesting in
this and that
they'll do excess because they come from
a place where they were way back in
their history they were kind of
subjugated they broke out of that but
they still have that that sort of that
that sense of stratification in their
society right upper class lower class
you know it's very political all the
stuff that's going on with bretton's is
always political
and we wanted to play with that in the
in the even in the architecture like we
wanted to honor that and so
even in the lower class stuff
that's still fancier than you might find
like it's not disheveled it's it's still
nice because these are people who think
that they can achieve if they want to
and we had a lot of fun just like
playing with that dynamic you know
the bretons in and of themselves are a
feudal society but the druids play a
part in this whole year yeah you can't
really have the bretons without the
druids they are
both inhabiting this place and they are
very different and they both have
different opinions of each other
obviously but you can see influences of
druidic culture throughout the whole
place and definitely in the art as well
it was fun to know all that was coming
later and just start to like carve out
the little pieces that we're gonna tease
in high aisle and then there's a whole
lot of stuff coming with them
especially concerning like the volcano
and these vents that are
spotting the aisles themselves and it
feels a little weird you're in this
beautiful place and every once in a
while you crawl over a hill and there's
a little volcanic vent spewing out you
know noxious gas and lava and why is
that happening has something to do with
the druids right right yeah yeah
biomes unique how
that's great well let me tell you
uh three through biomes we try to do
three biomes two biomes on this main
island right this the high isle itself
the the playground of the bretons right
so we've got uh oakenvald which is sort
of the verdant forest
we've got the sapphire coast which is
around down around the southern end
sapphira coast is where we got to play
with the somerset ideas because they're
only across the bay from each other
right
so
you'll sort of get that
a bit of that somerset uh sense there
but we had to fold in like the nautical
history of the island this is where the
great navy was built uh so many years
ago right i mean it's behind us right
now like we're surrounded by the the
remnants of that navy and the
treacherous nature of the seas around
the island so all that nautical stuff
got folded in there
and then we put sunflowers all over the
place because sunflowers are awesome
they're beautiful
and then we have aminos this
crazy escape from new york island you
guys threw at us
and there we got to play with like super
verdant rain forest it's a place where
i guess they just they just toss people
they don't like
yeah they're over there right there's
part of it where amino station is like a
stockade that kind of
separates the normal prisoners from the
ones they just ye out into the jungle
they're like there's the bad people and
then there's the really bad people that
we just don't even want to mess with so
those are the ones that just get
banished to the that verdant forest
there are so many things that want to
kill you out there and
so many gangs you know the green
serpents gang is out there so it's not
the place you want to be for sure it's
very pretty but it was fun to make yeah
it's gorgeous
i don't want to go there
do you have any favorite locations
stoneware grove is a great one that's
sort of our little druid village and
it's kind of part of that teasing the
druid culture to come
breakwater cave is great
the firepot cave is fantastic because
it's more of that volcanic connection
and it gave us a chance to
go underground and do something a little
more oppressive
and then i think my favorite right now
is ghost haven
because
i'm an 80s kid and every time i play
that one
i get a goonies vibe out of that
out of that adventure i can see that
yeah for sure
so those are some of my favorites
so taylor i talked a little bit about
how much fun it was for us on the art
side to get into the bretons but i mean
we should probably talk about them
a little deeper right with their history
who are these people the bretons first
and foremost they are feudal society
like we talked about they have their
nobles and at the top they are you know
stabbing each other in the back
political intrigue alliances arranged
marriages all that fun stuff and then
you've got middle class and lower class
they're very much the underdog society
if you will where the person at the very
bottom feels like they can always aspire
to something better and advance all the
way to the top it was the coolest part
about it because it's not what the elves
believe if you're born to a certain
you know status you stay there for the
rest of your life right brenton's like f
that we
took high rock we can do anything yeah i
think something that ties into that too
is like their nightly orders there's
three main nightly orders on high isle
and they all have their different
creeds and their different values but
they're all very prestigious and me and
have that kind of like romantic uh fight
for glory and honor and all that good
stuff this is a grounded story but the
bretons are innately
a magical race like they have this
affinity for magic
walk us through some of the trials with
that
it was very interesting to
try and keep a grounded story with
people who are inherently magical
but it's also it's fun to do that as
well because bretons and magic are
inextricably linked and their history is
linked to that as well and so there are
a lot of intersections between how does
that work in fetal society how does
magic
interject with your role there sometimes
you know magic can increase your
standing at court but it's also can
cause conflicts with your sense of self
you know
i think it opened up a lot of
opportunities for like character
development and not so much big grand
magic stories but more personal magic
stories it's not beams of death in the
sky this time right it's politics and
it's backstabbing and it's you know the
seedy things that are happening in the
back alleys of of a very well-off it's
not the cosmic threats right it is the
threats from within and the the focus is
on the bretons and their culture and
their race rather than big daedra coming
in and destroying the world
which is fun yes we love that yeah
this is fun too
so this year's storyline is a bit of a
deviation
from what we've done in the past kind of
walk us through that and what that meant
to the the the writing team yeah we're
doing the legacy of the bretton's year
so we are really delving into
who the bretons are because they are a
race that really hasn't been
explored much in elder scrolls lore
before we're really getting into their
history and their culture and we are
learning who they are
and our theme is kind of like a hope for
peace but tied up in all this political
intrigue and
backstabbing
right it takes us back to our roots yeah
you know we're we're really really good
at telling these very interesting small
stories where you learn more about the
individual characters in the world
and in politics there's always multiple
sides
to everything
clearly there is a
bad
guy faction and a good guy faction who
are the major players in the story the
ascendant order are what we would think
of as bad guys but their whole creed is
that they want to empower the common
folk they think that the common folk can
fight injustice on their own by losing
the shackles of the nobility and you
know uh freeing themselves from that
kind of bad leadership so that all
sounds great on paper but the senate
order is actually killing people you
know indiscriminately and not being very
nice so
we touched on the ascendant order is
there a leader
there is there is the ascendant lord
and then there's the ascendant magus as
well so the ascendant magus is his
second in command but they're both very
scary they're both very mysterious too
you don't really know a whole lot about
them no one does but part of the fun of
the story is that you are going through
it
and trying to figure it out and trying
to discover things about them and you
pick up certain pieces from the world
and
try to put it all together like a
mystery yeah
so the bretons as we've said up to this
point are kind of this medieval feudal
society
that must mean there's a bunch of
different houses different
bit players i guess in the story line
can you walk us through some of those
there are two i mean there's a bunch of
noble houses but there's two main ones
that the story really focuses on um one
is house dufort and they are the dukes
of high isle so they are the ones in
charge
and they are run by duchess elea and she
runs everything from castle nevir and
she is someone who is very fancy and
wealthy
but it's going to be up to players to
decide you know is she really serious
about fighting the ascendant order
threat
and then the other house that's really
important is house mornard and they are
technically rivals of house dufour
there's some bad blood between the two
of them and you'll find out why there's
history between them but house mornard
used to be in charge and they're pretty
salty about that
but they are also kind of partners of
house defort because house du4 is
concerned with shipbuilding and they
have shipyards and house marnard is
concerned with mining and trading and
they need house to fork ships to be able
to do that so they are rivals but also
need each other very much
you've talked about the defaults you've
talked about the menards
talked about the ascended order but
there's also this other society this
society of the steadfast and lord
vaccaro
how does he and that group play into all
of this
he's one of those people who just like
he uses his wealth to
make people's lives better he genuinely
cares about the people around him and
he is someone who tends to be very
sincere but he's also directed to the
point he is not um a fancy noble like
duchess soleil he is not you know
ascending order crazy but he is he's
just there doing his best
one of the things that i love about
chapters and story dlcs
is bringing back
characters that fans love it's something
that we always do
we get a kick out of it
who do we have coming back this year
that
players will be excited about
i love jacquarn obviously that rogue
he's always got his shirt off for some
reason really i don't know why
he does he loves having his shirt on if
i looked like that i would never have a
shirt on
look i love to hate jacquard is what i
mean
um but we've got him we've got captain
zaji who i also love so happy that
zashi's back the best he's the best he's
so good and casca is coming back so
we've got a lot of familiar faces that
players are going to be happy to see i
think
we've also got a bunch of new characters
as well yeah
lady arabelle comes to mind she is one
of my favorites because she is just the
coolest most confident
curious intelligent woman and she's
going to be the one who's kind of
guiding the player through the main
story which i think is really cool
because the two of you kind of develop a
bond through it and she is kind of not
your mentor but you just you rely on her
a lot and she relies on you a lot which
is neat i love that she knows what she
wants
and she is very straightforward yes in
all of her conversations which is which
is really great and yet she makes you
fall in love with her almost immediately
absolutely when you meet her like you're
immediately like oh
she's not her to the ends of the earth
right yeah yeah she's not afraid to be
like flirtatious or make an innuendo or
be snide to someone who's being rude to
her like she just has no qualms about
that at all
fair enough
in addition to the new storyline that we
have going on this year we also have two
brand new companions
and when you look back at blackwood
you look at the characters we had there
they were kind of stuffy kind of
prim and proper and or at least one of
them was
the player feedback was clear that they
really liked one character over the
other
and we really wanted to dig into
trying to find a better balance trying
to find a different feel and vibe for
these characters this year than than
last year
oh i'm just going to come out and say it
amber is probably my favorite out of all
of them
i love the character i love her
storyline
who is amber what's she all about
amber is a bit of a mess
i adore her she is a khajiit mage uh she
grew up on the streets so she really has
no qualms about violence or stealing or
fighting or getting into trouble in fact
she really likes getting into trouble
and she will probably get you into a lot
of trouble
as you take her around with her um but
she was just a lot of fun i loved her
intro quest i was laughing out loud the
entire time like i was trying to get
through it but i had to stop but like
that's just hilarious it is so good and
it's it's the character but it's also
kind of the environment and i'm terrible
with names i will totally forget the
name of the objective oh yes the tor
dreoc tower yeah i'm glad you said that
not me
just the towering itself is amazing
looking and just the the story that
we're telling there like i just i love
her so so much and who is amber voiced
by she is voiced by alicia rotaru so she
um most notably known from arrow
she is doing an incredible job she is
just knocking it out of the park as
amber so i'm really excited for players
to hear her uh and ember is khajiit
right so what what's what was the
impetus there why why'd we go khajiit
for her i mean truth be told it's
because khajiit are cool
they're just so different they speak
differently they act differently they're
a very very different culture
it just kind of made sense we wanted to
do something very very different with
with her and i think we knocked it on
the park with it yeah and then we have a
second
character uh who is
kind of the exact opposite of ember yes
named isabel i like i like isabelle a
lot yeah she's really great um isabelle
is uh definitely opposite remember she
is not a trash fire
oh my god she has her life together a
little bit more
but she's from a minor noble house in
high isle but she's not your typical
noble she's not snobby she's not stuck
up she's very down to earth
tends to be driven and eager and she's a
little bit dorky actually so like most
of us yeah exactly
kinship with her
we think that she's really kind of the
best of the nightly orders have to offer
on high isle because she is someone who
is driven to a higher purpose but she
has both feet firmly planted on the
ground when you meet her like it's the
the chivalry and the knights in shining
armor i love that one a lot and i think
our players in our community are going
to be pretty stoked at who voices
isabelle
yes she is being voiced by the
incredible laura bailey so it's going to
be really really fun to hear yeah we had
a lot of fun working with critical role
over the course of last year
and with the one shots and yeah we're so
excited to be able to bring her
along and and voice a character in game
i feel like the um like the systems team
and the writing team and the design team
really collaborated this time because
this is like our second iteration of it
and we tried to integrate ember and
isabel into the player experience yeah
there were lessons learned
around right absolutely we like listen
to player feedback and so there are
things like
uh when you go into combat we have more
lines now and more variations online so
hopefully you won't be hearing the same
repeated lines we also tried to get
their backstory into some more lines so
when you are standing around they're not
going to push you to move forward
they're going to be like waxing poetic
about
taffy or
telling you a weird
telling you a weird story about their
past so keep your ears open and uh
they'll have a lot of interesting stuff
to say the companion storylines this
time around are pretty personal it's
hard to talk about them without giving
them all away but even ember who's
really chaotic has you know this part of
her that is very guilty and has been
heavy for a long time and part of your
adventures with her is like helping her
lay that guilt down and meeting the
interesting people along the way and
isabelle is about friendship and growing
up and maturing so they've got some
really
wonderful beats in there i think that
are really fun you definitely want to
hang out with them more after you meet
them yeah which is totally agree yeah
totally great
like what you're hearing so far
we wanted to remind everyone that the
high aisle chapter is available to
pre-purchase now and includes a free
mount that you can start using in-game
immediately
visit
elderscrollsonline.com or your favorite
retailer today for those that are
watching and haven't tried eso yet our
free play event is live now until april
26th if you decide to pre-purchase the
high isle collection you'll immediately
unlock the base game in all previous
chapters and you can pick up right where
you left off from the free play event
both new and existing players can also
pick up the 2021 chapter blackwood on
sale now for a limited time
the high isle prologue quest is also now
live so anyone can jump into the game
and get ready for the upcoming chapter
even if you're just participating in the
free trial last but certainly not least
you can save on crown packs during this
limited time sale we have all the
details listed on our website at
elderscrollsonline.com
now let's get back to the discussion so
you can learn a bit more about our new
card game tales of tribute
in january we revealed a brand new card
game that is going to be releasing with
high island june tales of tribute we've
gotten a lot of questions about it most
prominently
why
always the most blunt and
straightforward
so i think that the biggest reason is we
wanted another way
to experience elder scrolls online we've
got lots of questing we've got lots of
killing what do
the people that live in tamriel do when
they go to a tavern other than drink
like what do they do to hang out with
their friends this was kind of an answer
to that what would a card game look like
in tamriel it was evident as soon as you
guys dropped the design on us because we
were like it's not small at all like and
we had to start thinking in terms of oh
this is a game that people in tamriel
have been playing for hundreds of years
right like it's like
it's like backgammon it's it's that
traditional right and
the extra added challenge that we threw
at you was this has to feel grounded
this isn't magic this is
what does it the game look like when two
people are just sitting at a table
playing back and forth but it's deeper
than that there's a story line that goes
with this thing there's like
world hooks into this thing right like
there are and there's there's pve is
what we're calling it where you are kind
of
learning the storyline challenging
masters there's a lot of like lore
titans too with the actual card game
itself so it really makes you feel in
universe absolutely and
it's focused more on kind of tamrielic
wide things like
yes the game kind of originated in high
aisle but it's propagated throughout the
world and so you're going to see the
patrons the unique decks
are kind of tamriel wide let's get to it
how do you play this thing right
fair enough so at its core tribute is a
two-player strategic turn-based deck
building game
you and your opponents are
taking turns building your deck trying
to
put the most you can into it to to win
the game and the way the game is broken
down is at the very beginning you and
your opponent each choose two patron
decks to put into play from there we
create our hands we get six starter
cards and then one card from each of the
the unique patron decks the rest of the
cards are shuffled into what we're
calling the tavern which is that
communal deck
and then you and your opponent play off
that deck you play your cards that you
draw you draw five at a time and then
you use those cards to purchase new
cards
to build your deck to work towards
whatever strategy it is you're working
towards to ultimately win the game and
one of the win conditions
could be if you have all four patrons
favoring you right
the other way is a contested victory
where
once you hit 40 victory points you win
so if we play a game describe to me the
turn order like what does a turn look
like at the very beginning
you will have
five cards in your hand
and what you do is you play your cards
generally it is play currency first play
action second
then you get the opportunity to choose
any cards from the tavern you can only
purchase cards that you have the
currency for or you can only do the
combat that you have currency for and
once your turn is done you discard to
your discard pile and then your opponent
goes when you run out of cards in your
deck and they're all in your discard
pile you just reshuffle and kind of go
from there and so it's one of those
things where you're constantly adding
new cards to your deck or
you could be thinning your deck out
that's a viable strategy and you're
constantly trying to build up
combinations of cards uh the strongest
possible hand you can have to
defeat your opponent what kind of cards
are there like what are the there's
different types right there's
essentially three basic types there are
action cards
which can range anywhere from giving you
gold to combat
to
forcing your opponent to discard cards
or for you to draw cards
there are contracts
which are essentially one-shot cards
where you can purchase it from the
tavern and once you do
you play it right away and then it's
done for the rest of the game and then
there are agents and agents are
cards that once you play they stay in
play
until your opponent deals with them so
there's that extra added level of
strategy all of that sounds a little
complicated but because you're dealing
with that luck of the draw it's very
easy to pick up and just hard to master
like even the people who are the best at
the game are still dealing with that
luck of the draw and your unknowns
absolutely and i think that's one of the
things that we've seen in all of our
play tests like we've
we've lost a lot of productivity due to
this game for the first time ever that i
can remember of we actually have people
sponsoring tournaments
within the studio
because they're so into this game and
what it means and how it changes things
so it's really exciting so can you talk
to us a little bit about how pvp works
entails a tribute yeah so it is
a game
in which you can challenge other players
i could walk up to cj
and challenge him to a duel or there is
a new kind of looking for group system a
queue that you can queue up for and
challenge random players in there and
that's all tied into a progression
system via rankings there are seasonal
leader boards that give you cool rewards
it's it's a fully fleshed out thing this
all sounds really fun but why play like
what is in it for us what is important
about getting victory at all part of it
is it just appeals to kind of human
nature everybody wants to be the best so
you want to win
but the other side of it is there's lots
of really really cool rewards here
there's
lots of cool cosmetics there's cool new
emotes there are
furniture crafting materials that you
can get out of this also transmutation
crystals and all available just by
playing just by playing just play the
game and you can get rewards you get
more if you win but you can get them if
you lose so there's kind of something
for everybody here
so this sounds really really fun uh when
can i play you'll be able to play this
on pts very very soon next week wow and
we totally understand this is a huge
game there's tons of information
i highly recommend you just jump in you
start playing it
it's really really easy to pick up
and it's difficult to master
for all of you eagerly awaiting the
journey to high isle the legacy of the
breton's year-long adventure is underway
in our ascending tide dlc
and as of today you can get a little
more of the story that leads us to high
isle in this year's chapter prologue
quest
grab the free crown store quest item a
letter from lady arabell to start this
quest
we also have our anniversary jubilee
event live in game right now celebrating
eso's eighth anniversary i can't believe
we've been doing this since 2014 and
have launched 33 major updates it's a
lot
so this year's anniversary jubilee is
going on through april 19th so don't
miss your chance to collect this year's
cake and take advantage of the double xp
bonus
now if you have a friend you've been
looking to start adventuring with or if
you're watching this and thinking about
trying eso for the first time you can
play for free now until april 26th
you can also pick up eso and crown packs
on sale now for a limited time
hi isle is just a couple months away
launching june 6 for pc mac and stadia
and june 21st on xbox and playstation
consoles and don't forget it's coming to
the pts next monday april 18th this
chapter is also just one piece of the
legacy of the breton's year-long
adventure and there will be two
additional dlcs launching later this
year that you can look forward to and
now we'd like to share the first
gameplay trailer for the elder scrolls
online high isle we'll be right back to
give you a look at how live game of
tales of tribute works with a guest from
our deaf team so stick around and we'll
see you in a few minutes
inequity rips at the very fabric of
society
the profligate few lead lives of excess
but comfort breeds complacency
these high born have no idea
what lies beneath
[Applause]
[Music]
society's outcasts are trapped here
but in the end
we are all trapped
a fish rots from the head down
and the only cure
is to cut it off
we
are the sword
we are
the ascendant
[Music]
[Music]
hi everybody and welcome to our high
aisle chapter preview post show we're
very excited to show you a live game of
tales of tribute for the first time ever
this is the new deck building card game
that is coming with the high isle
chapter
uh before we get started though we do
want to remind everybody that we are
raising funds for the gaming for ukraine
campaign hosted by team xbox in support
of iafaw the world central kitchen
international rescue committee and
unicef so if you'd like to donate
towards any of these causes be sure and
use exclamation point donate or
exclamation point charity in chat for a
link and a huge thank you to everybody
who has donated so far yes thank you
so today we're joined by two members of
the eso dev team rob and reneo welcome
thank you and they're going to be
walking us through a hands-on tales of
tribute game today we are going to be
playing on an internal server so please
keep in mind that some of what you see
might be work in progress or is work in
progress and so you might see a missing
icon here or there it'll look like a
little red question mark those will all
go into the game soon
um
so don't forget we are offering twitch
drops today we have a purple torch bug
pet and an orborus crown crate just for
watching for about 15 minutes and we are
doing an additional crate for everybody
if you tune in for at least 45 minutes
so we hope that you'll stick around and
hang out during our post show today
um don't forget once you get your drops
you have 24 hours to claim it through
the twitch ui so all you have to do is
visit twitch.tv
drops and you can claim from right there
so with all of that said let's get
started with our tales of tribute games
so rob renio thank you for joining us
today we are at um the bethesda twitch
studio live from their beautiful set um
rob did you want to just give a quick
once over for anybody who isn't familiar
with who you are um what you do over
it's awesome i've done a couple esl so
this is my first time here so it's nice
so uh yeah i'm i'm the lead gameplay
designer for esl uh what that means is i
oversee
teams that aren't working necessarily on
the content but on all the features and
systems so this would be things like
combat
crafting housing antiquities and of
course tales of tribute
and erenio first time on a live stream
with us so everybody please welcome
morenio
um you are on the systems team so what
is it that you do for esl yeah i'm a
senior systems designer and uh primarily
my responsive abilities have been all
pretty tribute focused i'm the the
product lead for tribute i've been
shepherding it uh throughout its
development um from some of the early
prototyping until uh
like we've taken it over put it in in
engine and uh yeah got it hooked up to
a lot of fun stuff kind of determining
what we should put in and what we should
leave out so today has to be really
exciting for you then
it's it's exciting i'm like nervous
a little bit i'm more looking forward to
seeing what players are going to do when
they get their hands on the game because
you know
you offer players the opportunity to do
stuff and they're going to come up with
things that you never think about
and
i love that yeah so
trying to provide them with the plethora
of tools to express themselves that's
what it's about for me
um so we are keeping an eye on chat just
in case anybody has questions as we're
kind of going along we'll do our best to
just keep an eye on things um but we are
going to let rob and erenio kind of walk
through
um kind of your typical match for a
tales of tribute game
so um we know rich went over a little
bit of this during the video that you
just watched but rob just very high
level basic explanation what is tales of
tribute
so yeah tales of tribute is a
it's a fully integrated
uh deck building strategic card game
that resides within eso it is not a
separate game it's a game that you play
within the game
um we have been
wanting for some time to explore this
idea of a tavern game uh something that
the inhabitants of tamriel would do
as a recreational activity what do they
do when you know their lives aren't
threatened by daedric princes or
whatever right they're pretty busy
normally so it's probably nice to have
some down time
but then for the players it's uh
providing yet another activity similar
to what we've done with antiquities or
fishing or something like that where
it gives you an alternative activity
when you want to take a break from
questing or running through dungeons or
trials or pvp so
this is probably
the biggest one of these we've done like
that fits into that category of an
alternative activity in the game uh but
it's it's pretty fun and you know
hopefully we we're excited to show this
here um but um
it it's uh it's when people think about
card game or they hear a card game it
often conjures very specific images in
their head
um
this is not a game where you are
buying booster packs or you know
carefully crafting a deck
prior to entering a game against the
competitor it is a 1v1 game by the way
um
it's a game where you do collect decks
and upgrade cards
but at the start of each game
all the cards that are selected to be
played in that game are shuffled into a
common pool that both players are
drawing from so there's no mechanical
advantage in this game for having more
cards or decks than the other player the
only real advantage you might have is
you might be more familiar with how to
effectively use those cards
and we'll talk a little bit more about
how you go about collecting those decks
and cards but i really think at a
certain point i could sit here and keep
talking about like what it is but i
think at a certain point it's probably
more helpful to just actually see it in
action for sure
definitely so we are uh well
we'll hop into the game here in a moment
yeah um so you know one of
one of the things that we've seen some
people asking is
you you can play anywhere but there
probably are some restrictions right
like we don't want people playing a game
and then get jumped in the middle of pvp
or something yeah it actually is pretty
flexible about where we let you play i
mean you can do it anywhere in the world
just about the some of the exceptions
would be um you can't do this enough
during a pvp activity
um
and uh done like
just before you know you're in the
middle of the dungeon probably not good
form to like hey hold on everyone i'm
gonna play this card game
uh so yeah we don't let you do it there
but there are numerous ways to actually
play the game so uh
you can play against npcs that are
scattered about the worlds some might be
harder to find than others
you can play against other players
either casually or competitively
you can
go to your friends list you can go to
your guild list there's a matchmaking
system
there's a a ranking system for
competitive play we'll talk a little bit
uh more about that later
but
it really is pretty flexible you know
it's like oh you know what i've got some
time i i want to play a match matches
usually we uh we like to think it around
maybe 15-20 minutes um
when we play today by the way i should
probably remark that our turns are going
to be unlimited time for the purpose of
demonstration in a real game you have 90
seconds for each turn that's a good
amount yeah that makes sense um speaking
of which let's go ahead and hop in game
so we can show this off because we know
that's what people are here to see they
want to see this in action so um
where are you right now in the game uh i
think we're on
a radio screen so we are seeing my
screen at the moment that's fine uh
we're in we're in gonfalon bay this is
an area of high isle um this is actually
where
you will
uh do the tutorial and this is important
because
completing the tutorial not only teaches
you how to play the game but provides
you the four starter decks that are
required to actually play the game
anywhere else okay so this will be the
first place you go when you want to play
tribute is here in gonzalon bay um the
npc's that you mentioned that you can
play are they all in high isle or are
they all three oh no they are scattered
about the world this this has this game
has caught fire in tamriel
um and and the npcs will tell you about
their passion for this game so
um
so anyway we're yeah we're here in in uh
gunflint bay i think uh so this is a
nice little
a little peak at high isle and yeah kind
of the main city statue over there i
don't want to show too much i'm
someone's going to get mad at me
uh so
yeah i think here we go we got irene
right here as i mentioned we could go to
the friends list um we could uh
we could use matchmaking or whatever but
you can also just like as if you were
gonna engage in a duel with another
player
uh you can just walk up to them and
select it the icon's missing right now
that'll be there soon but uh this is
dual and then this is how you would uh
challenge another player to a game with
tribute yeah so i'm going to go ahead
and accept that and in we go yeah
and there's a little glimpse at the
board we'll get to that in a moment but
first we're going to draft decks so this
is how every game begins and then you'll
understand why you need four decks to
play so at the beginning of each game as
i mentioned before each player picks two
decks to participate in this game
those decks must be
unique
so
the order of drafting we call it a snake
draft what is that a snake draft simply
means it's like an abba format so
one player picks a deck the other player
it's randomly selected who gets to go
first one player gets to pick a deck the
other player gets to pick two decks and
then the first player gets to pick a
final deck
so in this particular game so i only
have the four starter decks
and
erenio actually has unlocked an uh an
extra deck so you can see what that
looks like and that was three requesting
or yes there are numerous ways to do
this yes uh so
i should probably talk about what a deck
is though please do yes there's really
these
yes and that's the thing a deck is
really two components it's a
a suite of cards and then a patron and
all these things share a theme both in
terms of the lore as well as sort of a
mechanical play style of how you would
want to uh engage in this game
so
and what people are saying right now
you're using gamepad ui i am yes
you're going to be using controller
today um erenio is going to be using pc
so that way you can see the different
uis yes and kind of compare with them
we'll be going back and forth on the
screen you'll see each of our screens so
yes i'm using the gamepad ui here um and
so uh we'll talk a little bit more about
this when we get to the to the play mat
but the patron itself has its own
special power and then all the
individual cards have their own
behaviors um and i'll let erenio explain
that in a little bit here but i'm going
to start off by going with one of my
favorite decks and this is a starter
deck saint palin so st pellen is all
about generating power and putting
agents on the field
that will make more sense here shortly
what i mean by that but i'm going to go
ahead and confirm this and now erenio
will get to pick the next two decks yeah
so uh knowing rob as i do he's a sly guy
that uh
[Laughter]
yeah uh saint pelin definitely does
generate power which is a potential path
to victory but that agent side i don't
like so much so i'm actually going to go
ahead and uh pick
loremaster kelleris uh because
loremaster kellers actually has uh his
power kind of counters agents so
yeah that's you know you're going to
deny me some of my fun i'm gonna keep
you from executing your strategy
uh and uh as as rob called out uh
player two uh gets to pick twice in a
row so i'm gonna i'm gonna choose lure
master kellers and lock him in and then
as you can see i there there's that one
extra deck that i've unlocked that rob
did not have and i'm gonna go ahead and
pick that one because uh red eagles also
a very like strong power generating type
of deck uh but it's also got a lot of
cull like you know keeping your deck
lean and trim and i i like playing that
style so i'm going to lock that in and
even though rob doesn't have it yet
because i've chosen it we can both play
with it right
and so
you know culling the deck that's a good
point also this is one of the things
with this game is uh the deck building
when we say a deck builder the building
occurs within a game not outside of it
and so you'll see that as we start
playing right uh so let's see i've got
one left i have to pick between these
two because they're the only ones left
available i'm going to go with dukkha
crows
this this uh this particular patron has
a pretty cool power that lets you
convert
gold into power which is used to help
win the game but we still haven't gotten
to all the rules here yeah yeah yeah uh
if people play they'll probably find a
deck or two or a patron or two that it
is a style that they really like a
strategy that they really like
absolutely and this is another cool
thing is that when you do play against
another player who has a deck that you
don't you will get to play with that
deck even though you've never played
with it before again that's the only
potential advantage is mastery over the
mechanics of that right just being a
little bit more familiar with it yeah
familiar developed a little more skill
and experience
so i'm gonna lock uh this in and then
that's gonna take us to the actual play
mat and let's have a radio go over
everything there's a lot going on here
so we'll let it it is it's going to look
a little busy but uh so kind of going to
move a little left to right but shifting
things up as as needed
kind of on the left side there are these
three uh
card backs uh that each represent decks
um like on my board i'm gonna kind of
try and circle hopefully you guys can
see uh where my mouse is
like this uh on the left is is my play
deck uh which is composed of ten cards
and so is rob's on the other side
and it's
10 cards six
gold coins that's kind of just the basis
and then one starter card based on each
of the patrons that we've chosen so
for each patron deck that you choose you
get one additional card that's just
going to be something that seeds into
how the game is played from the get-go
and then you've got the
tavern deck that's what we call the
the mixing of the four decks that we we
selected
and those are all shuffled together here
and i'm going to kind of
oh actually that that one's on you uh
rob but
yeah if you click on that the tavern
pile in the on the left you can see all
of the cards that were mixed together
just to get a sense of what they are you
can kind of review them uh you'll also
be able to see all of these in the uh
the collections menu that's cool you can
see that anytime
yeah
so even if you know once you've started
the game people are drawing you're kind
of deciding on what to play you can
bring this up anytime and just kind of
take a look through everything yeah you
want to get a kind of sense of the odds
uh you know of what
when stuff might come up for you you
know if you're going to play the math
side of things a bit
and you know i do see a couple of people
in chat asking like you know can we get
mythics from these can we get items we
are going to talk about kind of what you
get from
playing and winning matches in a little
bit we will get there we promise
yeah they're excited they're like what
can we get
oh yeah
so uh coming out of there i just want to
i'll uh continue to explain some of the
board uh
so
right now uh the the kind of left side
again those are our decks and uh the the
shared uh pool that we're gonna be kind
of pulling from um
in the middle we've got kind of in uh
sorry we've got the gold prestige and
power resources in the middle on each of
our sides and those are some of the
resources that we're going to be
generating but we've got these five
cards in the middle
that are
cards that are available for each of us
to pick up on our turns so they each
have a gold cost up top and then they
have kind of the
what their effect is when you play them
uh the card may look a little busy but
i'll try and break it down uh you can
see that there's a dominant color to it
the one that is highlighted right now is
a blue it's one of the loremaster
kellerus cards uh this is important
because some cards have combos uh that
make them more powerful in this case
this card generates two gold and lets
you look like keller says about
foresight the sigix you know um so that
we kind of play again mechanically into
that and there's that icon in the upper
right corner that helps you identify
those as well right yep so it's that
it's blue and it's got that icon which
uh is also visible on the patrons on the
right side of the board
so you can think of it as a suit yeah
kind of like clubs hearts you know if
you're playing poker exactly that's a
good way to think of it yep so
this is one of the basic action cards um
there are a few types of cards uh in
this case uh we've also got an agent uh
available uh it's the second card and uh
that agent is a little different from an
action card uh it has an effect and also
at the very bottom there's a number and
uh that's how much health the agent has
that's how much
power uh one of those resources that we
generate uh it's gonna take to to punch
this guy in the face once he's on the
board sounds like my kind of card we try
and keep things uh a little punchy um
so
when you acquire a card you have to pay
the cost and then you add it to your
your cool down so you don't get it
immediately uh and then you know once it
comes up over the course of play you
then you get to put it into play
and
then you then your opponent in this case
is going to have to try and deal with it
or not necessarily
the other type of card so we've covered
kind of actions those just go into your
into your deck and you get to play them
when they come up agents which stick
around from turn to turn until your
opponent deals with them and then on the
right side of the board we've got a
contract and you can tell it's a
contract because of those extra cool
gold top and bottom parts you'll agree
there yeah yep and it calls it out as
well
cards
kind of yeah but go but uh the contract
cards are they're one-shot cards as soon
as you buy it it plays immediately it
never touches your deck but you get its
effects right then and there and they
can be more powerful than a card that
you might just pay for generically in
that regard
so those are kind of three of the things
that those are the three major card
types that you'll see and contracts
aren't just contract actions you might
have a contract agent
which goes into play immediately but
once your opponent deals with it it's
it's gone for good
so there's a fair bit of strategy into
figuring out do i want to improve my
deck by adding a normal card to it
or do i want to potentially you know try
and rush something like
push into the victory conditions yep
and if this is feeling like you know
you're you're kind of following but
you'd like to hear some of this again
you know like rob said there is going to
be a tutorial that walks you through a
lot of this we're going to have website
articles that kind of detail like what
the gameport is and what a lot of these
things do so this is not your only
chance like they're and once you start
playing too like a lot of it
it'll really start to come together yeah
yeah
yeah last last thing i'm going to cover
real quick is just the patrons on the
right side uh we alluded to the victory
conditions and the two victory
conditions are really one uh get to 40
prestige
and hope your opponent doesn't catch up
because they get blue yeah that's the
center blue one that we that you really
care about there uh
and if your opponent can't catch up in
on their turn you win
so that's a bit of a contested victory
because your opponent gets a chance it's
like putting putting your opponent in
check but they have the opportunity to
get out of it or you know put you in
check in response um
and then patrons uh patrons they each
have a you know something they're
looking for and then the effect
but they also have another component to
them which when you go to them and you
you choose to activate one and you can
only activate one per turn uh
they turn to favor you
so if you can accrue the favor of all of
the patrons at any moment in time you
just win the game right then and there
nice you've you've you've gotten them to
pay attention to you to care about you
you're clearly important
that's it you're cool so not only is
there a strategy to how you play the
patrons that you choose but also how you
want to win your win condition
preference yeah yeah the goal is
get the patrons to favor you or get to
40 first yeah so there's some playing
back and forth there that that rob and i
will undoubtedly do
you know we're going to apply pressure
where where it's uh most advantageous
so great with that let's dive in look
you're going to start sure let's let's
play a bit who's going first uh it's
rob's turn right now a couple other
things real quick here also is on the
right side over here there's you'll see
two other markers on the table yeah uh
that the first one is your your play
pile or your yeah it's the plate pile
yeah it's the played pile like i assume
once you put your cards into play they
go there and then this is the cooldown
pile that's going to be over here which
means cards that are will eventually be
reshuffled into your deck once you have
exhausted your your uh your deck so uh
and and this is we're going to get sort
of an illustration here of what mostly
turns involve it's basically generating
resources and using them to either
purchase cards in the tavern this middle
row or
to interact
say or and or interact with the patrons
on the right um also should be noted
that this particular patron here does
not favor anyone it is in every game it
is a neutral
one and it allows you to upgrade one of
your basic cards so um somebody in chat
actually had a good question sure do the
cards and the decks take up any
inventory space no are they separate
they're all part of your collections so
uh yeah no we're not gonna clog your
inventory with decks of cards and every
card
one card per inventory slot yeah we we
all know how precious your inventory is
yeah so i say there's a nine up there so
you can't afford that just yet right
yeah this is a this is a pretty
expensive card right here um the thing
is as you'll see also if there are cards
in the tavern that you don't really like
either because you don't think you'll be
able to afford them or you don't want
your opponent to get them there are
various mechanics available to you to
just get rid of them from the tavern so
so anyway so yeah let's let's get
started
here with your first turn right so right
off the bat here again this is these are
the basic cards that erenio mentioned
that gets slotted into everyone so this
time i got three basic golds and then
this card comes from the solaris deck
but it's the basic card it also just
gives one gold and this one comes from
st pellen and actually provides one
power so i actually have both gold and
power you can see i have four gold one
power uh again i can use that gold to
purchase any of the highlighted cards i
can also interact with the highlighted
patrons and this is gold that's not in
your bag correct this is separate from
like your characters correct
this is this is trails of tribute gold
and not only does it not go in your
inventory it doesn't even persist over
each turn
you have to spend it or lose it every
turn um so
let's see lots of solaris on the tavern
this time so um
although you know what oh this one can
remove
i don't know i think
i kind of like the idea of uh
[Music]
and remember normally turns are only 90
seconds right minute and a half so yeah
um so i do have four gold so i'm gonna
buy a uh oh man
pressure the pressure is on yeah
actually i'm gonna i'm gonna take a risk
here a little bit and i'm gonna go ahead
and buy this grind globe it's gonna
every time this card appears going
forward i'm gonna get two gold and i'm
gonna get to take two of the cards that
are in my draw pile and just move them
to my cool down pile so if there's cards
i'm like i don't really want those i
want my hand to be better i can move
them over so but you'll notice when i
buy this card it immediately goes into
my cool down deck
so i won't be able to see or use this
until i've gone through the rest of my
deck
so i still have two gold leftover i
could buy another card but instead what
i'm going to do is interact with the
treasury here as i mentioned before it
costs uh two gold to interact with the
treasury and then i get to choose one of
my basic cards here to upgrade to a writ
of coin this card would normally provide
me one gold the rid of coin will provide
me two so i just made my deck a little
bit better and that's what you're trying
to do every turn is just make your deck
a little bit better or apply pressure
with the patrons i really can't do
anything else because i have no more
gold uh i do have one power but i can't
interact with anything but what you will
notice is at the end of every turn
when you end your turn power is
converted into prestige as we mentioned
no gold is not power has turned into
prestige prestige is one of the ways
that you win um and there are some
additional rules that might prevent your
power from doing that we'll get to that
eventually so i'm gonna go ahead and end
my turn all right
so for my turn uh
i've got
well very similar stuff to what rob had
uh but you'll note oops well i've played
two treasury cards they each generated
one gold i actually as the second player
start out with one bonus gold and the
reason for this is because uh it
kind of counters the first person
advantage of getting uh to take a look
and first shot at all of the stuff in
the tavern i think that one extra gold
can be super powerful
because you can just afford a bit more
you can potentially you know
have up to six gold to play with on the
first turn
sadly i don't quite but that's okay i
don't mind getting a little bit of power
and drawing even with rob uh yeah on
that front one thing i want to note is
you are seeing both
of their screens as we go back and forth
normally during a match you would only
see your own but we're showing you both
for the sake of showing off a match yep
so yes now that i've picked that up hmm
okay i've got five gold and one power
so i'm a little concerned there there is
as rob called out a lot of colorist
stuff on the board uh i'm actually going
to purchase this one uh that i i like a
bit it's uh it provides with options it
doesn't really it doesn't provide gold
by default um
but uh i'm gonna pick that one up just
to kind of keep rob from running away
with like a keller's combo deck
and then
since i i was trying to be smart about
it i had five gold i knew i'd have two
left over afterwards i'm going to go
ahead and also
use the treasury to get rid of one of my
basic cards and uh not fall behind in
terms of uh the gold race
and i'm gonna call it at that for my
turn
oh and as as soon as you purchase a card
you'll see that that's replaced on the
tavern so sometimes if you've got a
bunch of gold you might want to buy
something cheap to you know
open up some options for yourself
all right oh um somebody said they see
that hourglass there you just tap on the
or you click on the hourglass when
you're ending your turn correct and then
it automatically moves to the next
person for their turn yeah it's the
equivalent of saying like if we were
playing in real life a card game yeah
exactly
one of one of the cool things though is
that uh when you end your turn it
immediately shuffles your next hand to
you which means you can already be
planning your next turn while your
opponent is playing you don't have to
sit there and wait now you probably want
to pay attention to what your opponent
is doing it may adjust your strategy
they may take something that you wanted
but uh it does it isn't a complete
surprise as soon as your turn comes up
yep so three more gold and while you're
kind of deciding on what to do with your
turn rub um somebody was asking if the
90 seconds is for pve and pvp games and
i believe it is for every question
either one right yes
uh although
not necessarily because oh well uh
oh not i'll just be mean but uh
npcs aren't going to complain if you
take too long right so another player is
so
yeah you've got more time to play
basically issues right against npc's
mistake for sure yeah i'm also thinking
because we've had discussions about
even within pvp casual versus uh uh
competitive like we've had discussions
over time about like what timers should
look like so
yeah um okay so we all learned something
today yeah
um
four gold and one power this turn to
play with uh after i used all my cards
uh you all notice now my my my draw pile
is empty which means at the end of this
turn all my cards are gonna get shuffled
in
and i get a
new
my all the cards i've just added in will
now be playable
so
let's see
more solaris again
i'm just short of buying this one
yeah i mean this is kind of i already
have one of those
this one would remove from the tavern
but i don't think i want to do that yeah
i'm just going to go a little bit harder
on i even though i like st pellen that's
not what the game's really giving me
right now so i gotta adjust
um
i'm gonna upgrade another i'm gonna do
this basically the same this is the
exact same turn that i returned yeah so
that is all i can do once again i have
one power remaining and i'll end my turn
i'll get a prestige and my deck will be
shuffled into my draw pile yeah now
these cards in your draw pile he doesn't
have them right no our our draw piles
are unique from each other right okay
yeah yeah what he what he's picked up to
modify his deck you know that's
that's the point of divergence right
right you know right we start out the
same and then everything goes from there
perennial looks like you're about to eat
this plant here i'm just going to move
it out of the way for real could use a
little more fiber
there we go
nothing appreciates that here the plant
probably wouldn't appreciate it
so uh yeah like like rob i'm gonna just
right now it's still early game so i can
pretty easily just play through all my
cards and i've also got uh wow i think i
actually had like basically a virtual
mirror matches to what rob had but uh
this time rob's purchase of uh
one of those colors cards uh opened up a
card that i really like uh from the red
eagle deck so i'm actually gonna pick
this up it's it's one of those
the art is really good
yeah the the art is is definitely
gorgeous like the team
did an amazing number on some of these
um so i'm just gonna pick this up
because uh yeah it's pretty power
centric and i like that
but that there goes all my cash monies
so i'm gonna flip my turnover and like
rob now
now i could draw anything
i will do my best going forward here to
pronounce it correctly i keep saying
celerus that's just hardwired into my
brain from the first time i ever saw the
word
okay so
this turn is going to get a little more
interesting because we're going to see
our first combo so
uh let's see
so what is a combo oh actually will we
get a combo
we will not never mind i was wrong
because i do have two of the same suit
but neither of them has a combo effect
so uh that's very sad um
so
let's see there's my rid of coins so
that's the card i upgraded earlier so i
have extra gold another gold
power
and then i'm not only here's my my
special effect here i'm gonna get two
gold and then i'm gonna get to decide
uh i'm gonna get to take two of the
cards from
my draw pile and just move them to my
cool down pile which means i get to skip
those cards so if you have cards that
are on the weaker side of things or not
really what you want at that time you
can be like yeah i just want to move
those all away at least for this round
they'll still get reshuffled back into
my deck eventually
so i'm going to select both of these
actually because neither of these is
particularly special
so you'll see they moved over
and that's the power of this of of
caloris i said it right
uh it's a lot of modifying it's
basically trying to cuss more get to the
cards you want quicker yeah um both in
the tavern and in your deck so now i
have six gold
and one power so my purchase options
have opened up here for sure
um and while you're trying to decide on
which card to purchase rob i just kind
of want to go back to
kind of the basics of tales of or
details of tamriel tales of trivia
there's a little plug for one of our
podcasters um
so again the goal here is to get that
blue number in the middle you want to
get to 40. or you want all of the
patrons which is on the well i guess the
way you all are seeing it
the right side of the table
pointing towards you so they're all in
your favor
they're all neutral right now pointing
toward the board
and this is a deck building game
and
um each turn is a minute and a half
typically but we turned that timer off
yeah we turned it off for this just so
we have a little bit of time to explain
so turns are also going to go like
faster and faster as the game progresses
yes yep yeah
yes all right so
lots of things to pick here
i like both of these cards they're both
they're both duke of crows cards but
they do different things
uh
the interesting thing here though is if
i grab this one i could still buy
another i could i could interact with
the treasury again um
[Music]
yeah we'll do that oh and that was a
contract card i
i was not paying attention
i missed it all right that's okay it's
okay because i'm gonna get another two
gold and i'm gonna get to shuffle even
more things out of my
my hand here
my draw pile i kind of like that rid of
coin though so i'm gonna leave that one
and just get
oops i missed it
i pressed the wrong button it's okay
it's not the end of the world actually
on that one but uh let's see i've still
got four gold
[Music]
what to do
choices you know i'm gonna get some
power here and start doing like just
that we need to see this so i'm going to
use the duke of crows okay uh what this
will do it'll take one of my gold
uh and i pay that as a cost and then my
remaining gold converts to power which
later will convert to prestige
so go ahead and do that
and my turn yep and now you can see i
have six prestige down because i did
that now i still made some mistakes
there and i imagine irene is probably
going to punish me on that so we'll see
[Laughter]
we'll see how much i can punish you i'll
i'll certainly try
[Laughter]
was that too mean no no no oh for
these streams no that was that was very
vital you're good
all right all right
uh okay so i've got a couple power and a
couple of gold and now i'm going to get
to pick one of these cards to remove
from the board
[Music]
so
[Music]
you know i think i'm actually going to
remove this uh this contract action from
the board okay
okay and just see what that opens up for
me
and then i'm gonna
toss both of these uh from the top of my
deck because starting gold is not not as
worthwhile
but yeah oh got four money remaining
hmm
oh
you know
i think i i think i need to pick up
that keller's card
oh no well i'm not a fan of that but oh
well i'll make do
that uh opened up even more
duke of crows cards which
i know rob likes
i did pick that deck in the beginning
all right let's see what do we got here
gold power gold two gold and a power so
four gold two power i can pick up one of
these duka crows cards
and that's a that's some good gold and
power generating if you can combo it
right that's a key thing there is that
until i get more duke of crows cards
this card will doesn't really do that
much
so
but there's also
that's another contract
i don't want to buy another contract
we also have this over here by the way
if you wanted to i could just pay two
power right now and it would let me draw
another card and if i go over here i can
look at what's currently left in my draw
pile so it's no g this is not an order
though you don't know which of these
cards you would get
so
that's risky
i don't think i'm gonna do that i think
i'm just gonna go ahead and take this
that is gonna leave me with only one
gold
unfortunately but
um
let's see yeah i don't actually have an
agent right now
what normally happens if you run out of
time during your turn it ends your turn
it's like it clicks the button for you
no pressure
yeah i still could interact with this
and start applying some uh patron
pressure and it would let me draw one
more card
i'm already ahead by two power let's
just do it for fun
you know i would be curious to see what
happens once you guys get past this turn
if you just start taking turns like you
normally would and see what the pace of
the game looks like we can we can keep
time yeah and we will be 97
and we can watch for questions in chat
in case you're going too quick and
something comes up okay i'm down but if
you come across any brand new like if
you get a combo maybe we'll stop and
talk about that yeah all right so i get
to toss another card here to like shave
my uh my my draw pile down i'm going to
select that one remove it and let's go
okay all right
um
still three gold
that seems like my best option
yeah let's use it or lose it yeah yolo
it
i don't want to toss any of these though
can you not yes uh anytime you are asked
to toss or remove multiple cards you can
do up to that number or you can do none
at all which is what i'm going to do
here nice
that's some power generation there that
just became available st pellen has
appeared yep
prompt
oh right
all good
so okay we're now just straight up
playing these as they go so
just gonna do that
all right hmm
you know
i think i'm gonna pick this up just to
keep rob from getting it because i know
i know how much he likes it right
so there's three goals in yeah
let's get all the patrons in your favor
get to 40 or screw over rob
[Laughter]
and uh i've got a little bit of extra
power i could just let that convert into
prestige to try to catch up to rob but
i'm not really liking the uh the patron
pressure so i'm actually gonna
set one of them back to neutral
and uh redraw sadly leaves me with one
goal that i can't spend so that's that's
that but uh
yeah we'll do what we can
ah once again i have two of the same
suit but no combo coming off it let's
see
seven gold though i do that's a lot
i don't want a contract
oh man i get to play with you guys
helen oh i could also oh my goodness an
agent so here's the problem though yeah
i want to do this agent but it's so easy
for him to remove it
because of the three because of colorist
the color is patron power yep uh that's
why he picked that after i picked saint
pellen
which is funny because this is even a
saint paul and agent all right uh you
know what no yeah i kind of like this
idea that i can get two of these in one
turn yep
oh hold on let me wait okay now i'll
stick with that
[Laughter]
i love your
you're unsatisfied
i mean that's it it's fair you know i
was i was trying to deny him one thing
and he got another set of options
i'll take my licks when needed all right
i'm just gonna again
keep keep the ball rolling
and this time
okay
hmm
[Music]
are you gonna get the agent
no i i don't think i'm going to i'm
going to remove this card
and i i just don't have enough money
right now which is frustrating
um oh i don't want to toss either of
these that's both great
all right keeping them both there then
and uh
all right
yep i'm going to leave myself with
one left over again but i i am building
some some sweets
giving opening up
every time you pick up a card from that
tavern you risk what your opponent may
be getting yeah exactly all right yep
i get to do this again
oh no i'm not
you know what i'm going to take a risk
on this one yeah
and and pull the rit of coin out of
there oh
that's for a future turn that's not for
this turn but yeah i get to do this
again and this time
[Music]
nope
nope not gonna do it
and
one power
two more power but i don't think i got
the combo on this one yeah so
but i can get closer to a combo with
this one
okay three of those cards now i now have
three saint pelins cards
you got four actually because you start
off with one from every deck three three
from the tavern one that everyone said
you should always start like
with one basic card from each patron so
there's a strategy to trying to collect
the same suit number or color of cards
does it matter if it's the patron that
you chose or is it good practice just to
try to collect one color
i mean it depends on what's appearing
there's definitely uh as soon as combos
start coming into play being able to get
more the same color is great but if you
just go too hard into one suit like it
might not be providing you what you need
specifically to win yeah it's also a lot
easier to counter if someone only has
really ones one thing going for them
that makes sense
and again we expect a typical game to
take about 15 or 20 minutes we just
turned off the timers here while we were
explaining at the beginning
so they're intended to be you know a
little bit faster um just very casual
matches that you can play during
downtime if you're kind of i don't know
waiting for your group to get together
or something
yep
ah no more
sadly i gotta leave two gold this time
but that's okay
oh there's two nine cost cards up there
now yep
so um while erenio goes and does his
turn rob can you talk a little bit about
um some of the things that players get
from winning matches
sure i mean uh let's see there's
a lot of stuff i know one of the things
players will be particularly excited
about is trans music i was just going to
say that yeah
there's definitely uh transmute crystals
especially if you're playing in the
competitive uh
ranks
so yeah but there's a bunch of cosmetic
stuff you can earn as well there's uh
you know furnishings we're actually
adding a new house guest i'm not going
to talk about who that is yet
that's a surprise
and uh there's a pet that you can earn
as well as i mean obviously
earning decks and cards as well um you
also get like sellable items and that
type of thing and i should point out
when it comes to decks and cards
you're earning fragments of decks at
which point when you complete the
fragment set you have the whole playable
deck but on top of that
there are cards that upgrade cards
within that deck
and those you can earn uh there's some
special
um
clues that you can find while engaging
in other activities in eso and those
clues will give you hints on how to find
special tribute stashes scattered about
the world oh cool
but you don't have to have the upgrade
cards to play
you just have to have a completed deck
and while all this talking has been
going on i had a pretty excellent turn
now i'm going to pull really far ahead
of rob
yeah 14 now okay all right
let's see
for the furnishings is uh are some can
we expect some of them to be tales of
tribute themed yes
yeah i don't know i don't know how much
we should be spoiling right no no that's
another
that's a reasonable expectation we
definitely thought that this would be
something we could we totally imagine
players will set up their own like
personal tournaments inside their houses
so you can play this in your house
absolutely you're in game house yeah i
mean obviously you're in your regular
house too but i mean you can take your
laptop and go play in the park too you
know
okay
and so erenio people will only be able
to duel
others that own the card game right
right yeah yeah
and so what happens if let's say i own
high aisle but you don't and i duel you
do i even have the option to duel you or
is it just like an auto decline type
thing sadly not yeah like they both both
players have to have high eyes right the
icon just won't even show up yeah that's
it yeah yeah but that's kind of typical
of all of our you know chapter features
i just pulled a card completely that's
why you destroyed it yeah that was new
yeah also
even though he doesn't have an agent
check this out yeah
i now have okay i'm spoiling this
because normally i would i would be
hoping hoping that i'd be paying a
notice
but i just uh i now have three of the
patrons favoring to me so now i've
applied that pressure
so i basically i have to he has to
activate like i have to do something
with a patron otherwise rob could just
sneak a victory like that and that will
probably cost him resources oh you
better believe it
sadly oh i had a a a very close to
starting goal gold turn there but
uh let's see hmm
oh i really would like to be able to
purchase this one but i can't do that
and oh no wait can i
hmm
i could but you'll just get rid of her
oh
blair oh actually never mind i thought
that was an agent my mistake um contract
yep contract
you know i'm actually gonna do that
and i'm gonna have one gold leftover i'm
gonna i'm gonna be smart about this i'm
gonna get rid of two of my starting gold
for good
and then
oh look i've got just enough to to swing
the tuca crows back to neutral and
avoid the potential loss right there
okay
let's go
gold
gold
three power
so now i'm see there's saint pelin
coming into play now i'm generating a
little bit and i'll get to do a little
more uh hand calling here oh but i like
bam man that doesn't feel good
uh we'll leave it
it's okay
uh
let's see
yeah if he had play if he if he even did
have an agent this card is a huge threat
it's only two gold to basically remove
an agent from your opponent's table so
yeah
um
oh man more of that
from the tavern
i don't know
i mean
what's interesting here is i can kind of
do a double whammy not by any cards go
ahead and hit the duke of crows now i
have seven power that's all going to
become prestige so now i've got both
pristine a little bit more prestige
pressure and patron pressure on him nope
not liking it uh not a fan
all right well
who
i want to know while you're going
already oh yeah oh man i wish um i wish
i could run a twitch poll right now i
just want to know who people are rooting
for in chat are you team rob or are you
team
you can just ask people to post and chat
there you go
it's nice and easy okay
well should i even tell you all what
they're saying
i'm gonna be disappointed if irene
doesn't beat me here because he's been
living and breathing this game for a
long time
oh but i'll do my best i'm not i'm not
some of this is luck though yeah so here
i'm actually going to toss a card that
has has a cost because i'm planning to
activate
red eagle
and thus i know exactly what i'm going
to draw oh
so now i'm going to draw this card and i
knew that i played a duke of christ and
i'm going to get to draw two cards when
i play this one
are you going for a combo oh yeah that
was a combo that was
okay and and i already play the red
eagle so now i'm also going to get this
combo
so i just i just got 10 prestige this
turn
and some extra cash monies oh wow so
yeah i'm i'm
living the good life right now
uh what are you gonna do with that and
i'm just afraid
that this is gonna unlock something
useful for rob but i'm gonna do it
anyway
uh yep of course another duka crows card
for him yeah oh well okay well i just
want you all to know chat was pretty
split between the two of you however
rich is on team moranio
sorry rob
of course he is
all right
let's see i did get a little bit of
power
all right man
um still no agents in play yet it's
unfortunate we haven't really been able
to to show that during this game but
nope it's a risk neither of us is
willing to take it so far this card does
let you draw more cards so that's good
oh man that's a lot of contracts that is
a lot of content
of agent punching contracts yeah i mean
i feel like i need to keep putting this
pressure on here
it's fair yeah oh
okay let's let's let's shave down the
hand again man really
these are nice would you be willing to
toss
the basic basics yeah basic gold or even
even an off-suit uh a card right like if
it's uh if it was something that i'm not
playing a lot of then again i'm kind of
playing all three of these suits right
now and i may be spreading myself too
thin and doing it
but it's a lot of what's been available
yeah so
man
i mean i could just burn these i can't
really interact with any more patrons
but then i'm risking giving a radio
something fun to play with actually no
let's let's go ahead and do this i just
get three two power out of it so yeah
that's worth it
and that's my
all right well
i'm catching on that prestige but still
he has he has considerably more prestige
generating capability than i do right
now i think well it depends on how helen
plays out yeah okay you two are very
good at like countering each other
that's also i think one of the reasons
why this match is going a little longer
yep i'm gonna i'm gonna actually get rid
of both of those right now
and see what this opens up because i've
got some money and oh
okay
yep i'm gonna be picking up oh no but i
can't he he's got three favoring him
this is
oh no i can
it's dangerous almost caught myself okay
but i i'll still have a gold leftover
after this so i can turn that back but
oh man
that that could have been oh that could
have been dangerous so dangerous i am
not getting any combos this turn
unfortunately
while rob is glad to hear that yeah
right
while rob's working on his turn i did
just want to remind everybody that um
during today's stream we are raising
funds for the gaming for ukraine
campaign
hosted by team xbox so if you would like
to donate towards any of the charities
that we're raising money for today you
can use exclamation point charity or
exclamation point donate in chat that'll
bring up a link in chat so that way you
can be directed over there there's the
the big old turn
okay and i'm gonna get rid of this
because i i know you want that armory
card rob
generating five power turn would be
crazy and i can't afford it
so oh no and
uh
that doesn't generate power so i'm not
i'm going to push try and push towards
the end right now because
he is that's that's risky so close
so
yeah actually i could do it right now
i'm going to put you in check rob
there you go
yep 41 putting you in
there's no way wow that i'm going to be
generating that amount of prestige with
with this particular hand in one turn
it's not an automatic win once he gets
40. you still have a chance it triggers
the end of the game yeah and so it's
incumbent upon me to either match or
exceed his total and it goes back and
forth until either a yeah someone can't
match or exceed or if someone hits 80
that's it
you hit 80 you're done yeah
there is one other thing that could come
up which is the patron victory if you if
you get the patron vector you still win
instantly so if i was if i just went to
like 41 and doing so he was able to flip
the patrons he would win right there
before it got back to my turn okay so
well unfortunately this is gonna be the
end for me the best i can do is just
earn i think some earn some more uh
yeah it's going to be short but
congratulations good game
gg gg good match
and again normally normally matches
don't last as long as it did with robin
oreno playing against each other because
they did take a lot of time at the
beginning to kind of explain how it
worked and kind of walk everybody
through but typically they're probably
at least half that amount of time right
yeah and we hope that all the
information was helpful all the talking
through their strategies and information
all the cards uh you also asked earlier
about rng yes absolutely there's random
elements in this game part of the skill
of the game is being able to manage that
risk and
make the best you know take the risks
where you can
there's a song about that no one to hold
them and all that yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we'll have to get you to sing that
one eventually not this stream not on
the street not not the okay
statues oh that's great yep that's your
trophy congrats
oh yeah so um once you win
um
i see on the screen well
we did on this screen over here it says
victory um at that point do both of you
collect rewards or is it only the person
who wins uh so in a well what we played
was a friendly match so there wouldn't
be rewards for just that because there's
a possibility for abuse but like say we
say we match mate or went through the
activity finder to play uh we would both
collect rewards
winner winner collects more of course
but uh yeah you get something for
winning and you get something for you
know not winning
we call that losing here wow
yes
that's that's a nice way of saying it
see rob you participated i did
i participated very hard you tried
anybody who has young parents knows
about that
yes
alrighty well
i think that just about does it for
today's stream i know we had um a lot of
questions about again how the game works
and people want to try it out but we
will have website articles kind of
detailing
um just kind of the anatomy of the game
board and just kind of basics and you
can look out for a lot of those guides
once we're on pts too
additionally we do have a lot of preview
content that is coming out today from
press and from content creators who kind
of got an early look at this so you can
definitely check out some of that from
um
youtube channels and i'm sure they'll be
putting up articles so they'll be
explaining kind of
their experience playing against other
players and npcs and such
so that's it um we want to remind you
that there is a lot going on with eso
right now including the chapter prologue
quest for high isle anybody can hop in
and play that right now
including everybody participating in the
free play event which is also happening
right now until april 26th
there's also our annual anniversary
anniversary jubilee anniversary
anniversary
because eso did just all
right and that's going on april 19th um
and then also blackwood the eso base
game and crown packs are also on sale
right now a whole lot going on
um so don't forget also to pre-purchase
high isle
that is launching in june and will come
with tales of tribute that you saw today
yep and we mentioned this earlier in the
previous video but um pts is starting on
monday so in just a few days so you'll
be able to try high isle and tales of
tribute the new trial we saw a lot of
people asking in chat about how they're
excited about the trials so you'll be
able to jump in there and try dread sale
reef
update 34 is also along with that so if
you follow us on twitter at tess online
we posted um essentially like a road map
image with all the things coming in
update 34 so definitely check that out
if you missed it um but yeah that'll be
on monday with a pcna character copy so
it's pretty exciting i know we've been
working working towards pts for a little
while so
it'll be great to get people in the game
trying things out you can stream if you
want there's no like nda or anything if
you're on pts
um and we also have a number of
international teams kind of across the
globe hosting various recap streams so
we have them for
france germany italian spain you name it
like the whole list is on our website
including the schedule so those are
starting on tuesday running through
thursday so if you missed anything today
and you are
elsewhere in the world
you can definitely check those out
and drops will be on for those as well
and
i think that's it for you today so
thank you so much everybody for tuning
in thank you everybody who donated
towards our charities for the gaming for
ukraine campaign yes thank you thank you
to rob thank you
for joining us right back at you yeah if
i could say also thank you to the team
absolutely that's working their butts
off trying to get this thing together
and yeah everyone they have done a
phenomenal job like i am so proud of
each and every one of them
and not just the development team but
also just a lot of supporting teams a
publishing team
i.t has been working a lot getting the
stream together
marketing sales pr all of them like this
has been um definitely a team effort
putting this event together and getting
everything on the pts and getting ready
for chapter launch in june it takes a
city to build a game definitely does
yes and please try out tales of tribute
on pts next week
and um yeah i was gonna say have a great
weekend but it's only thursday but
regardless
you can have a great weekend and also a
great friday
um and thank you for joining us today
thank you all all right take care
everyone thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you